so for me hope is not like some abstract
consideration it's sort of a
prerequisite for my survival but I do
understand it's kind of a funny fuzzy
word like the word hope just has a
slight like live laugh love connotation
not that there's anything wrong with
living and laughing and loving I'm just
trying to understand what we actually
talk about when we talk about Hope
anyway good morning Hank it's Tuesday
let's get a check of the weather even a
grizzled melancholic weather person like
myself has to acknowledge that it is
absolutely glorious oh also I understand
we have some breaking news a couple
weeks ago a major work of art called a
leaf emerged from the branches of this
tree and then over the next couple weeks
several million more major works of art
emerged so that's nice I think by hope I
mean that I need to believe that
Consciousness is worth it that like
biological awareness which of course
comes with much misery and consternation
and pain is nonetheless valuable it's
valuable to learn about weaves it's
valuable to look up at the stars and try
to figure out how and why and when and
where they are even if that knowledge
won't last forever because nothing lasts
forever I still think it's valuable I
think it's valuable to read beloved and
Othello we're watching iCarly with your
daughter yes or watch iCarly with my
daughter actually I completely agree
with you so when I talk about hope I
guess I mean that I need to believe that
love and connection and art and
collaboration are for lack of a better
term worth it but I also mean I live in
hope that the human story will go on if
not forever and also that it will get
better if never anywhere close to
perfect like over the weekend I saw an
elderly man receive a hat and it was a
very fancy hat it was encrusted with all
kinds of minerals and stuff and the only
thing all those minerals had in common
is that they were from every corner of
the earth except the corner of the Earth
where the elderly man in question lives
it was a very curious event but it
reminded me of how much can change
change because just a few centuries ago
we would have given that elderly
gentleman not just the fancy hat but
also like absolute power over an entire
Kingdom making the hatman into a
ceremonial position seems to me like
real progress albeit insufficient
progress there's still much Injustice
and how power and resources are
distributed in our world but still that
doesn't negate the reality of progress
these used to be pepper seeds in my
bathtub but now they're full-fledged
pepper plants in my bathtub almost ready
to be planted in the garden Margaret
Atwood once wrote that very little in
history is inevitable and I believe that
oh
oh no
there's anything isn't normal I never
sneeze but right so Margaret Atwood once
wrote very little in history as
inevitable and I believe that I I don't
just think we can change the world
together I think we will and I believe
in hope that we will change it for the
better and that's the kind of hope that
for me holds up to scrutiny the kind
that sings the tune without the words
and never stops at all so that's why I
am despite everything like broadly in
favor of humans I look at what we can do
together and I am odd I am also
horrified of course but I need to make
space for both of those realities like
there needn't have been a hospital here
that's happening because tens of
thousands of people from around the
world and across every imaginable
barrier have made it happen but it is
equally true that there should have been
a hospital here many decades ago believe
me I understand the urge to simplify
experience and nothing is simpler than
despair but I don't think any Simple
Story tells the whole story so all hail
complexity Hank I'll see you on Friday